vous l'avez beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup demandé en commentaire je vous
comprends
voici enfin aujourd'hui le test du
samsung galaxy à 70 ce qui fait partie
de cette nouvelle gamme de smartphone
milieu de gamme gamme a en tout cas qu'à
lancer ça me saoule en 2019 en gamme à
elle réuni l'entrée de gamme et milieu
de gamme si vous avez suivi un peu
l'histoire vous savez que l'année
dernière ça me saoule proposé d'ailleurs
depuis quelques années la gamme j ai
vraiment l'entrée de gamme et la gamme
acquis et et milieu de gamme
on parle pas de la gamme s le haut de
gamme très haut de gamme et la gamme
note pareil présent très haut de gamme
là on a une gamme à qui unifie l'entrée
de gamme et milieu de gamme pour
proposer qu'une seule même et grande
gamme la gamme art le a70 est issu de
cette gamme qui se situe plus dans le
milieu de gamme bien évidemment mais le
chiffre est un peu plus haut à 70 on
commence bas à 10 à 20 heures avant eux
je les reçois on en parle aussi dans
quelques jours voilà il y en a pleins il
ya eu à 50 que j'ai testé ya pas
longtemps et aujourd'hui grand temps
venu de france n'est pas très française
il est venu le temps en tout cas de
parler des 570 qui se situe juste là le
smartphone est cool est intéressant il a
des points ils sont vraiment intéressant
vraiment positif
il ya aussi des points un peu plus
mitigé le mieux c'est encore de vous le
montrer de vous en parler comme ça vous
saurez
[Musique]
je vais être extrêmement transparent
avec vous pour moi ça me souffle et
trois promesses sur ce galaxy à 70 la
toute première promesse c'est l'écran un
grand écran de 6,5 pouces résolution fhd
plus de 1400 pixels par 1080 pixels
ratio de 20 ne vienne ça c'est un assez
exceptionnel on avait souvent futiles
époque en tout cas les ratios 18/9 18,5
9e 19 ne vienne 19 points 5/9 c'est ce
qu'on a en ce moment et là on a du 29e
alors c'est vrai que le vingt neuvième
c'est un format un peu à part on
retrouve le 21 9e notamment sur le sony
xperia one grand format cinémascope
là on est un peu dans l'entre-deux on
est sur un format 29e ce pharmacien de
vienne il est intéressant lorsque vous
voulez regarder du contenu cinéma parce
qu'on se rapproche du format cinémascope
vous mettez par exemple une vidéo sur
netflix ou sur youtube c'est vraiment
bien vous avez ce grand format
cinémascope pas quasiment cinémascope on
est sur une forme à vingt neuvième et ça
c'est vraiment vraiment hyper après sa
brouille et c'est quelque chose de très
très très long on a juste ici cette
petite encoche qui somme toute ne pose
pas trop de problème alors c'est vrai
que c'est toujours surprenant parce que
samsung avait dit fut une époque ne
jamais vouloir l'être d'encoches là ils
ont mais une encoche ils ont succombé
c'est une année de transition un très
clairement l'encoche en 2020 va
disparaître mais pour l'instant elle est
encore là on a donc un écran super
lumineux très grand très agréable pour
regarder des vidéos pour du contenu
multimédia pour dit je pense que vous
voulez ça s'est vraiment bien et ça
c'est la première promesse qui est fait
par samsung et il faut reconnaître que
samsung ait une vraie maîtrise dans
l'art des écrans écran super amoled avec
une excellente qualité très lumineux
vous soyez en intérieur ou à l'extérieur
vous profiter vraiment d'une belle
qualité des noirs a fini des super
contrat sans fard à joues pas c'est un
peu l'histoire c'est vraiment vraiment
hyper agréable en plus en point de vue
logiciel pour faire quelques
modifications vous allez dans un fichage
vous pouvez activer le filtre lumière
bleue moi je n'utilise pas ce que ça
casse quand même pas mal la lumière
bleue c'est vrai que c'est bien au
niveau du mode d'écran les suisses en
mode naturel sauf que les couleurs sont
quand même beaucoup mieux rendu beaucoup
plus sympa vous n'êtes pas forcément
vous en rendre compte tout de suite
parce qu une colorimétrie sur la vidéo
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même
mieux après poyer sur les couleurs vives
ça va être un peu plus tonique les
couleurs on est debout
plus éclatant d'un peu sursaturé
beaucoup moins naturel moi j'aime moins
je me sens vraiment le système naturel
je vous conseille réellement et je
conseille d'activer le cuistre de
lumière bleue ça va venir à peu l'écran
mais dans l'absolu c'est quand même bien
et il faut penser à se protéger les yeux
une fois de plus c'est hyper important
ce grand format est bien mais c'est vrai
qu'il a malgré tout quelques points un
peu négatif déjà je crois que le
smartphone est un petit peu large donc
en termes de prise en main ça va ça
fonctionne mais c'est pas hyper hyper
évident en plus comme vous avez
informatique quand même relativement
allongez vous allez forcément utilisé à
demain c'est pas hyper évident à une
main on sait on est sur un smartphone
avec un écran de 6 pouces de notre côté
c'est pas surprenant qu utiliser une
main ce soit compliqué mais c'est vrai
que l'expérience est parfois un peu
complexe et je vous dis même pour
l'utiliser à une main sur le bas de
l'écran du fait qu'il soit un peu large
voilà et on fait toujours garde parce
qu'ils tombent pas donc pour moi c'est
un smartphone que vous allez utiliser
quasiment en permanence à demain en haut
vous soyez vraiment le roi pour utiliser
un smartphone comme ça il fait retourner
sans faire tomber dans le cas contraire
il faudra utiliser avec demain il ya
plus de sécurité
donc ça c'est la première promesse
première promesse tenue
deuxième promesse c'est la photo la
photo avec un trip module vous avez un
capteur principal de 30 2 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f
1.7 c'est le capteur grand-angle de 78
degrés vous avez ensuite un second
capteur de 5 mégapixels qui lui sera là
pour notre portrait qui ouvre à f 2.2
est aussi vous avez troisième capteur de
8 mégapixels qui lui par contre l ultra
grand-angle est lourd aussi à f 2.2 est
il un nul très grand-angle 223 de grèce
un smartphone qui est assez intelligente
avec de la reconnaissance de scène
ce qui fait que lorsque vous allez
pointé par exemple bien sûr de leers pas
reconnaître de hertz a optimisé la
couleur la colorimétrie la saturation la
luminosité pour de l'herbe la même chose
ancien la même chose le chien d'animal
un plat ce que vous voulez ça va
vraiment dire optimiser sa marche bien
c'est bien vous avez aussi les arn
bojidar y est enfin le truc est assez
cool en extérieur est dès lors vous avez
de la lumière le rendu et c'est naturel
rendu assez qualitatif
on voit bien les détails sur la feuille
poyart zoom un petit peu on perd pas en
détails les couleurs sont justes tout
est relativement bien mais dès que vous
arrivez sur l' ultra grand-angle tout de
suite les images sont quand même moins
saturés - au lit il ya tout de suite
moins de détails c'est moins beau et
vous
voyez il ya un problème d'exposition
l'âge et des graviers c'est extrêmement
blanc de vie n'est absolument pas la
matière des graviers l'ultra grand-angle
123 degrés et bien pour faire des essais
quand vous avez beaucoup de lumière mais
on va pas avoir une superbe maîtrise
derrière a contrario ce capteur
principal de 30 2 mégapixels dès lors
vous avez beaucoup lumière ça marche
parfaitement bien le rendu est vraiment
superbe
la voyez on a bien la couleur des fleurs
tu l'as bien les couleurs verte la
couleur marron du sol et dès qu'on
arrive sur l' ultra grand-angle to ship
c'est beaucoup moins beau y est moins
bonne gestion de la lumière des couleurs
je trouve que la qualité quand même
vachement moindre là dessus il faut être
plus un capteur principal ça marche
parfaitement bien la gestion des
couleurs du détail tout ça c'est
vraiment bien même lorsque gm rapprocher
et ça marche parfaitement bien et
d'exactitude juste un grand-angle c'est
beaucoup moins saturé beaucoup moins
précis une gestion des couleurs qui
quand même moins dans l'expo est pas
folle voilà je resterai masse est mitigé
sur cette ultra grand angle
la caméra de cette fille par contre on
fait le job vous avez une caméra telle
fille de 30 2 mégapixels une ouverture
de f 2.0 elle sait parfaitement bien le
boulot le rendu est correct et vous avez
en plus une partie d'un grand angle
dessus alors excusez moi pour cette
tranche matinale
fuchs matin c'est pas hyper hyper
évident mais voyez ces prix exactement
la même distance le rendu est bien dans
les deux cas même si je préfère quand
même celui là madame des fous de cet
appareil c'est la faute aux nuits la
gelée pris la photo sans aucune lumière
dans le studio sur mon petit perso qui
vous fait un gros bisou avec son doigt
photo nuit s'est tout de suite assez
compliqué il faut briser votre
smartphone pour le stabiliser si les pas
stabilisée vous prenez une photo à la
main le rendu va pas être terrible
terrible et si vous le faites avec l'
ultra grand-angle on capte absolument
rien il ya plus lumière qui rentre c'est
vraiment pas terrible
bon là n'ont qu'un smartphone qui frappe
parfaitement jobs dès lors vous êtes en
extérieur que vous avez beaucoup de
lumière le rendu sera bien sûr la caméra
de 30 2 mégapixels ça marche
parfaitement bien c'est pour moi le
meilleur capteur photo sur ce smartphone
dès que vous arrivez sur l' ultra
grand-angle
c'est un peu moi ça le rendu est pas
forcément hyper hyper qualitatif je
reste quand même assez dubitatif là
dessus je vous dis une fois de plus en
extérieur pour faire des photos un petit
peu what the fuck pour capter des
monuments des choses comme ça ça sera
bien vous aurez moins de saturation
moins de détails pour l'expo c'est un
peu plus compliqué pour des souvenirs ça
marchera et le mode portrait fait aussi
très bien le faire le détourage est
plutôt fidèle à ces honnêtes avec le
stand ragone 675 foyers au niveau des
doigts là ça vient quand même
relativement
un détour et c'est assez précis là c'est
pareil entre les doigts puisque c'est
bien rien coûter un peu flou alors qu'il
était posé sur un pied on a un rendu qui
est correct c'est pas le rendu le plus
fou que j'ai pu trouver en tout cas au
niveau du mode portrait mais pour faire
des souvenirs publiées sur les réseaux
sociaux
ça ira bien au niveau de la photo est ce
que samsung tient ses promesses avec ce
galaxy à 70 et bien sûr un peu mitigé
sur la caméra principale à 30 2
mégapixels joug d'une fois de plus ça
marchera très bien il me remplit en tout
cas sa mission en faible luminosité
c'est un peu moins salée on va pas non
plus trop lui en demander mais sur un
smartphone scouts 409 euros dans le
milieu de gamme dont bon il faut raison
garder par contre je trouve que dès lors
qu'on suit sur les autres capteurs c'est
tout de suite moins précis moins beau
moins juste les couleurs sont assez dé
saturer les expositions sont un peu plus
compliqué donc pouvoir sur un triple
capteur photo il y en a un vrai manque
il fait le job
voilà je suis assez mitigé pour moi la
mission est remplie à moitié
alors après attendait ça dépend vraiment
de ce que vous voulez en faire si vous
voulez faire des photos pour des partage
sur les réseaux sociaux ou conserver des
souvenirs à titre personnel ça marchera
parfaitement mais n oublions pas qu on
est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme à
409 euros c'est pas the photophone c'est
pas le smartphone qui vous fera les
meilleures photos
néanmoins le rendu reste quand même
relativement honnête et la troisième
promesses c'est l'autonomie avec une
énorme batterie de 4500 milliampères
heures c'est beaucoup c'est une grosse
batterie je sais pas si vous êtes
coutumier des chiffres au niveau des
batteries mais sans lesquels beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de stockage à côté de
ça on a de la recharge rapide 25 watts
vient avec ses strict minimum parce que
les recharger une très grosse batterie
comme ça il vous faut forcément quelque
chose qui la charge assez rapidement
l'autonomie moi je trouve vraiment
excellente et ça c'est une des promesses
faites également parce un tour de
chauffe aussi une promesse qui est
vraiment remplie vous le gardez deux
jours sans problème
alors bien évidemment l'autonomie ça
dépend toujours de vos usages de votre
façon de consommer du multimédia la
luminosité que vous allez mettre essayer
ça si vous passez tout votre journée
dessus il ya besoin d'un petit peu
compliqué mais si vous avez un usage
standard vous garder deux jours voire un
peu plus si affinités on a bien
évidemment de la recharge en usb type
ces jeux
ça marche parfaitement bien c'est aux
petits oignons donc là on a les trois
points les plus importants le focus fait
par samsung sur ce smartphone la up
il est là tellement bref un grand écran
panoramique format vingt neuvième super
amoled
mission remplie la grosse autonomie avec
la batterie mission remplie la photo
mission remplie à moitié
reste un petit peu moyen sur ce point de
vue là à côté de ça c'est un smartphone
qui tourne avec instinct dragon 675 qui
est un soc milieu de gamme de qualcomm
qui marche bien tu vas pas être le truc
le plus dingue pour avoir des grosses
performances sur les gros jeux notamment
du fort ce night ou du pib j'ai dit
qu'on a des jeux 3d on va être sur les
résolutions assez faible néanmoins vous
lui ferez tournée saint georges sera
vous n'achetez pas un smartphone à 409
euros pour faire tous nos petits groupes
titre y avoir beaucoup de puissance donc
bon je trouve que c'est à ses rêves de
l'absurde à 6 giga de ram 128 go de
stockage extensible grâce à une carte
micro sd à 512 gigas si vous le
souhaitez vous allez en plus deux cartes
sim plus une carte micro sd dont vous
êtes quand même pas mal de possibilités
sur smartphone qui est assez flexible
de ce point de vue là pour prolonger
l'expérience multimédia vous avez un
haut parleur mono situe juste assis sur
le côté alors leçon va pas se mentir est
pas géniale du tout vous avez ensemble
est quand même relativement fuyard s'est
ré médium d'un petit haut parleur qui
développe pas une puissance de dengue a
à côté de ça y'a un truc qui est
vachement courjault ce smartphone si
vous avez une prise jack qui est
conservée qui est là donc ça c'est bien
et c'est même plutôt pas mal du tout
parce que vous pouvez effectivement
venir poser votre petit casque sur votre
tête venir écouter votre musique et en
plus sur ce que vous avez à faire mon
truc est en cours je vais pas y arriver
aujourd'hui
et en plus dense que vous venez le
brancher sa vous activer d'autres
options au point de vue logiciel dons
manuels dans son et vibrations vous
aller dans les paramètres de son avancée
dans qualité effets sonores et une fois
vous débranchez votre case vous avez
l'option dolby applause que vous venez
active et ça s'est vraiment bien ça va
vraiment améliorer significativement la
qualité du son et vous allez aussi dans
la date semble alors moi j'ai entre 30
et 60 ans je ne vais pas 60 ans plus
proche des 30 que les 60 musicalement
cette france là et ça va venir corriger
les défauts de fréquence de vos oreilles
relativement connus et ça va vous
permettre de compenser les fréquences
que vous pourriez potentiellement perdre
dans cette tranche d'âge donc c'est vrai
que c'est pas mal là par contre on a du
fond là vraiment
son du meilleur son et ça change un
petit peu toute l'histoire donc c'est là
où le côté un peu multimédia vraiment
intéressant avec ce smartphone c'est
lorsque vous avez utilisé avec un casque
en bluetooth ou alors avec une prise
jack asra faisait du bluetooth 5.0
regarde un film comme ça en ne tenant
dans le creux de la main juste avec le
haut parleur
c'est franchement pas terrible par
contre si vous voulez profiter d'un bel
et des vidéos sur youtube mais pourquoi
pas la vidéo de monsieur groupe vous
branchez votre casque vous mettez au
bout tout ce que vous voulez et tout de
suite ça marche beaucoup mieux pour moi
il ya deux gros points forts sur ce
smartphone à cet écran avec son ratio
29e qui vous vraiment bien pour le
multimédia
vous mettez une série vous mettez un
film au casque avec la grosse autonomie
derrière vous êtes tranquille vous
pouvez consommer du contenu multimédia
vraiment pendant longtemps et c'est
vraiment pour moi le gros focus est le
gros point fort de smartphones si vous
aimez consommer du multimédia avec ce
smartphone vous allez vraiment pas être
déçu parce que pouvoir encaisser pendant
des heures avec une excellente qualité
maintenant la question c'est le
positionnement tarifaire par rapport à
la concurrence
est-ce que ça va suffire à samsung pour
en vendre beaucoup oui non quoi comment
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas est ce que vous pourriez lâcheté
est ce que vous l'avez acheté est-ce
qu'il vous tente
comment vous le situer par rapport à la
concurrence vous autour de 400 500 euros
une offre qui est énorme avec de très
très belles machines
comment vous trouvez qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire et si vous intéresse vous a
mis un lien bien évidemment juste en
dessous vous pouvez y aller à moi
maintenant vous faire de gros mais qu un
je vous fais des bisous wiki c'est
clairement le studio c'est mon chéri
savent alliotte vient de faire un bisou
à papa wingles option oblats bouge pas
thiel terme avions wiki rien fouet les
moins chers bon allez manger j'arrive
j'arrive voilà je vous fais des minutes
on va les manger allez salut ou bisous
ou et bonnes aptitudes